[موسيقى]
بتوقيت الرياضه انا صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
تفجيره سد نوفا كخوفكا على طاوله مجلس
الامن بعد قليل بطلب من روسيا واوكرانيا
واسطه تخوفات من غرق مدن اوكرانيه
اعاده افتتاح السفاره الايرانيه بالرياض
بحضور ممثلينا عن وزارتي الخارجيه
السعوديه والايرانيه
نتنياهو يعين مستشارا اعلاميا لرئاسه
الوزراء معروف بكتاباته التي يعتبر فيها
بايدن غير مؤهل لمنصبه
قادما من ريال مدريد كريم بنزيما رسميا في
الاتحاد اتحاد جده السعودي لكره القدم
بعقد يمتد لثلاث سنوات
[موسيقى]
وصلت موقعتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه
ومباشره الى مجلس الامن الدولي حيث تبدا
الان بعد قليل اذا جلسه مجلس الامن الدولي
على خلفيه تفجير سد نوفا في خرسون في
اوكرانيا وسط تبادل الالتهابات بين
الجانبين الروسي
والاوكراني حول المسؤوليه عن استهداف هذا
السد واستهداف البنى التحتيه في هذه الحرب
البنى التحتيه المدنيه طبعا ما ادى الى
مخاطر كبيره مخاطر بيئيه كذلك
وطبعا تعرض القرى والمدن المجاوره كذلك
لخطر الفيضانات بسبب تفجير هذا السد اضافه
الى امكانيه تعطل او تاثر محطه ذا فولوجيا
النوويه بسبب انها تحصل على المياه من هذا
السد الذي تم تفجيره اليوم سد نوفا في
خرسون
اذا تبدا الان وفي انتظار كلمه المندوبه
الروسي او المندوب الاوكراني كذلك سنبقى
اعيننا ايضا على جلسه مجلس الامن الدولي
لتفجير السد
عفوا الى المشاركه في اجتماعنا
فقرر الامر على هذا النحو
[موسيقى]
وفقا للقاعده التاسعه وثلاثين من النظام
الداخلي المؤقت للمجلس ادعو السيد مارتن
جرافيث وكيل الامين العام لشؤون الانسانيه
ومنسق الاغاثه الطارئه الى المشاركه في
اجتماعنا هذا
فقرر الامر على هذا النحو
ايضا مشاهدينا كما ذكرت
سيتحدث بعد قليل سنبقى اعيننا ايضا على
كلمات المندوبين خاصه المندوبين الروسيه
والاوكراني حول هذا الهجوم تفجير سد نوفا
في خرسون ونعود تباعا لمتابعه اي تصريحات
هامه خلال هذه الجلسه
اذا الصراع الروسي والاوكراني مشاهدينا
يدخل منعرجا اكثر خطوره باندلاع ما يسمى
بحرب السدود فشده الصراع بلغت حدا لحد
استباحه مرافق حيويه حساسه ما قد يؤدي الى
كوارث بيئيه وانسانيه خطيره الموضوع يتعلق
بتعرض سدك خوفك للتفجير في واقعه هي
الاولى من نوعها منذ بدايه الحرب
الاوكرانيه مياه السد الواقعي في مدينه
نوفايا كخوفكا التي تسيطر عليها روسيا في
منطقه خيرسون خرجت عن السيطره وباتت تهدد
المنطقه باكملها بفيضانات
[موسيقى]
ونعود الى جلسه مجلس الامن حول تفجير هذا
السد مارت يتحدث
وهناك 40 مقاطعه مغموره بالمياه او
جزئيا في مقاطعه خرسون ومن المفترض بهذا
العدد ان يزداد في الايام المقبله هناك
تاثير نتوقعه في المناطق التي هي تحت
السيطره روسيا ونحن نحاول الوصول الى هذه
المناطق لتوفير المساعده الانسانيه منظمات
انسانيه والامم المتحده
اطلقت عمليات في محاوله لمعالجه تاثير هذا
الحدث هناك رده طارئ
نقوم بتنظيمه لتوفير مساعده الطارئه لاكثر
من 16 الف شخص متاذن وهذا الدعم يشمل
توفير المياه مياه الجافه والمساعده
النقديه والدعم النفسي والاجتماعي هذه
الجهود تكمل رد الحكومه الاوكرانيه بما في
ذلك توفير معدات اضافيه مثلا مولدات
الكهرباء
معدات تصفيه المياه المتنقله ونقل المياه
بالشاحنات وهذا الامر اساسي بعد
الدمار هذا هناك افرقه متحركه متعدده
الوظائف تم نشرها الى
الحافلات والى
القطارات في خرسون لدعم عمليه الاجلاء
والمدن في الغرب تستعد
لاستقبال الاشخاص الذين
يتم اجلائهم عندما تحدثوا عن الوضع في
اوكرانيا منذ ثلاثه اسابيع القيت الضوء
على الماسي مااسي المدنيين
والضحايا بسبب النزاع الدائر من ناحيتي خط
التماس واشرت الى الخسائر في الرعايه
الصحيه والمياه والكهرباء والتدفئه للالاف
هذا بالاضافه الى العدد المرتفع للمهجرين
والهجره القصريه
الاخبار التي وردتنا اليوم تعني ان هذا
الوضع الماساوي للشعب في اوكرانيا من
المفترض ان يتدهور ان هناك حاجات انسانيه
فوريه من المفترض ان تزداد بسبب الفيضانات
في الايام المقبله
وسنستمر بتقييم الوضع وتقييم الرد
وهذا السد هو مصدر اساسي للراي الزراعي في
جنوب خرسان وفي شبه الجزيره القرب وان
الفيضانات التي تستمر والتي نشهدها على
شاشات التلفزه اليوم ستعيق انشطه الزراعه
والمواشي ومصائد الاسماك بالاضافه الى
نتائج واسعه النطاق وعلى المدى البعيد
وهذا هذه ضربه كبيره للانتاج الغذائي وهو
متاثر اصلا
وانه اعبر عن مشغلنا مخاطر
التلوث بالالغام والاجهزه المتفجره بما ان
هذه الفيضانات يمكن ان تحرك هذه الاجهزه
الى مناطق اعتبرت على انها امنه وهذا
الامر يشكل خطر لعدد كبير من الاشخاص
فهناك على الاقل 30% من اراضي اوكرانيا
ملوثه بالالغام وفقا للسلطات الاوكرانيه
والى مقاطعه هي الاكثر تاثرا في اوكرانيا
وان دمار السد يمكن ان يؤثر سلبا على
توليد الكهرباء بالاضافه الى ذلك اي
انخفاض غير مضبوط في مستوى المياه في خزان
كخوفكا يمكن ان يؤثر سلبا على امن
محطه توليد محطه النوويه
وزملائنا في الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه الذريه
يقومون بمراقبه الوضع عن كثب وما من تهديد
فوريه تم الابلاغ عنه حاليا وما من وصول
الامم المتحده لمعلومات مستقله فيما يتصل
بالظروف التي افضت الى
دمار
السد كخفك الكهربائيه الى ان القانون
الانساني الدولي بغايه الوضوح المرافق
التي تحتوي على
قوى
خطيره مثلا السدود ينبغي ان تحظى بحمايه
خاصه
تفادي هذه الخسائر
المدنيين ينبغي التركيز على
المدنيين والبنى التحتيه المدنيه اثناء اي
عمليه عسكريه وايضا يكون نوعها وهذا الضرر
بسبب دمار السد يعني ان الحياه حياه
المواطن ستكون اكثر صعوبه
وهم يعانون اصلا من هذا النساء
نتائج في توفير نتائج عدم توفير المساعده
للملايين من الاشخاص المتاثرين بالفيضانات
في هذه المناطق يمكن ان تفضي الى وضع
كارثي ونحن مستعدون لكي نقوم بكل ما هو في
وسعنا لتوفير المساعده نحن نعبر عن قلقنا
البالغ ازاء الاشخاص المتواجدين في
المناطق المتاثره
ويتعادل علينا الوصول اليهم حاليا
ونحن مستعدون من الناحيه اذ لا تشغيليه
لكي نتحرك مع القوافل المشتركه بين
الوكالات وتوفير المساعده في المناطق تحت
فتره روسيا الى شعب اوكرانيا
مشاهدينا نكتفي بهذا القدر من كلمه المفوض
الامم لشؤون الانسانيه مارتن جريفس يتحدث
عن تضرر اربعين بلده غمره المياه بسبب
تفجير سد كخوفكا في خرسون وبان الوضع
الانساني يتدهور بسبب هذا التفجير نبقي
عينا على جلسه مجلس الامن ونعود لمتابعه
الاخبار على ان نعود الى الجلسات تباعا في
حال وجود اي تصريحات مهمه
بمجرد تداول خبر تفجير السد لم يتاخر
طرفان نزاعي في تبادل التهامي حول المتسبب
في هذه الكارثه الرئيس الاوكراني ذهب الى
تشويه هذا الهجوم باستخدام اسلحه الدمار
الشامل كما حمل الرئيس الاوكراني روسيا
مسؤوليه التفجير مطالبا للعالم بالرد على
الهدوء
نعود الى جلسه مجلس الامن الان فازلين
مندوب روسيا يتحدث
هناك فيضانات والملايين من الاشخاص ينبغي
اجلائهم وتم البدء بعمليه الاجلاء هناك
اضرار هائله تم تسبب بها خصم بالنسبه فيما
يتصل بالقطاع الزراعي اود ان اؤكد ان قائد
الجيش الاوكراني يرغب
بتدمير هذا السد للحصول على منافع عسكريه
وهدمت
وهذا ما اشارت اليه 2022
جنرال الجيش الاوكراني كان يريد ان يتسبب
فيضان النهر وكان هناك عمليات استهداف
لهذا السد كخفقه وتم كسر ثلاثه
مواقع في السده لكي يروا يمكن لتدفق
المياه ان يؤثر على المواقع السوريه دون
الروسيه دون ان يؤثر سلبا على
القرى المجاوره وكان ذلك كحل يمكن اللجوء
اليه نهايه الاقتباس ونحن اكدنا ذلك
للاسره الدوليه
والمجلس الامن وارسلنا وثائق رسميه مذكره
من البعثه الدائمه فيما يتصل بمشاريع نظام
كييف
لتدمير هذه المحطه وناسف لان نداءاتنا
للامين العام للامم المتحده
للقيام
هذه الكارثه وانه لم يتم التوقف عند هذه
المستندات واخذها على محمل
الجد
وكان تم تشجيع لكياف من الغرب وذلك
لارتكاب هذه
الاعمال الارهابيه من الصعب ان نقنع اي
طرف
بان هذا النزاع في اوكرانيا هو بسبب عمل
روسيا
الجانب الغربي يرفض
الاعتراف بانه تم الاستعداد لهذا الانقلاب
في ميدان والمناهض للدستور وهذا الامر
بالاضافه الى تدابير متخذه ضد الناطقين
باللغه الروسيه في الشرق
ودون الاقتراف بحياه المليم من الاشخاص
العمليه العسكريه الخاصه الروسيه وضعت حدا
لهذه الاعمال وهناك بعض المعلومات المنسقه
او حمله للمعلومات المغلوطه واعلانات طنان
من الغرب ومن كاف بشان هذا الموضوع
وسنستمع الى هذه
التصريحات اليوم وتقول ان هذا السد تم
تخريبه من قبل روسيا
هذه الاقوال تذهب في الاتجاه نفسه هي
المنبثق من الاعلانات الخاصه بمحطه
وهذا انفصام في الشخصيه هو نتوقعه وان هذا
التخريب المقصود واستهدافنا تحتيه اساسيه
امر خطير للغايه يمكن ان يعتبر جريمه حرب
او هجم ارهابيه الى البنى التحتيه التي
تحتوي على مواد خطيره امر محظور من
القانون الانساني الدولي وهذا السد والشيء
السدود يشار اليها في الماده السادسه
وسبعين لمعاهده
عام 57 هذا التخريب اهدافه واضحه اولا
توصل الى شروط لاعاده تجميع
لوحدات الجيش الاوكراني
والاطلاق
عمليات عسكريه
وهي تشهد وهنا وهذا بالاضافه الى عسكره
الجانب الشرقيه
لشني
الهجمات الهدف الثاني من هذا هذه الهجمه
هو
الحاق الضرر بسكان هذه المنطقه وتدميره
هذه البنى التحتيه الهائله سيفضي الى
اضرار واسعه النطاق وان السلطات خير
تقوم باجلاء المواطنين في المناطق التي
يمكن ان تصبح مغموره هذا التخريب افضل الى
كارثه ايكولوجيه
ومئات المناطق الماهوله مغموره على بقرب
اي كيف تحاول
ان تحرم
سكان نجم جزيره القرم من هذه من المياه هو
في الوقت نفسه سلطاتك
تستمر في
زياده منسوب المياه في خلال عبر السد
وعمليه التخريب اذا كانت مقصوده ولتواصل
النتائج وخيمه لكل سكان المنطقه جرائم
نظام كيف
واستمرار الغرب بتوفير الاسلحه لها هذا
يعني ان ينبغي بكيف والغرب ان يتحملوا
مسؤوليات هذه الكارثه وهذه النتيجه
التكتيك من بدات في 2014 لاستهداف البنى
التحتيه المدنيه وذلك لتوصل الى اضرار
كبيره للمدنيين وهذا الامر محظور بشكل
واضح من قبل الماده والخمسين البروتوكول
هذه
ارهابيه من النظام الرسمي وهو يفتخر بهذه
التدابير دارياد وعمليات
الاغتيالات الاخرى
نحن نفهم من يقوم بتخطيط هذه الامور من
يقوم بالاستعدادات ومن يدعم
عمليه التخريب على نطاق واسع لا نفهم كيف
يمكن للامانه العملي والمتحده ان ترفض
ادانت نظام كييف وتقول انما من معلومات
كافيه مثلا يمكن ان تتذكر ما حدث مع محطه
نوويه نحن نعلم ما كان مصدر عمليات
الاطلاق القذائف
وهناك عدد من المداخلات السياسيه التي
تقول انها نتيجه اعمال الروسيه في
اوكرانيا هناك انكار ورفض
لا يمكن ان نفهمه الاحترام الحياديه من
قبل الامانه وذلك وفقا للماده 100 من
الميثاق ان وجدع للامانه لكي تتوصل
استنتاجات
موضوعيه وادانه تدابير كياف نشدد على هذا
الموضوع علينا نلقي ضوء على ظروف هذا
العمل الهمجي ضد كخفقه علينا ان
نتفادى تكرار بوتشا ونور شكرا شكرا لممثل
الاتحاد الروسي المواقع على هذه المداخله
والكلمه الان
لممثل البانيا شكرا السيد الرئيس اسمه لي
ان اشكر السيد على احاطته
مره اخرى نحن نشهد هذه الاخبار الفظيعه من
ايضا مشاهدينا الكرام لكلمه
الروسيه في مجلس الامن اتهم فيها ما سماه
نظام كيف بارتكاب جريمه لا يمكن تصورها
بتفجير سد محطه كخوفكا للطاقه الكهرومائيه
سنبقي عينا اذا على جلسه مجلس الامن التي
تناقش تفجير هذا السد والجلسه للتذكير
تعقد بطلب اوكرانيين اما قد اتهم على لسان
ناطقه الرسمي لمثل بسكو وبالتهمه اوكرانيا
بتدمير السد وذلك بهدف حرمان شبه جزيره
القرم من المياه كما اعرب الكرملين عن رفض
موسكو الشديد لتهامات اوكرانيا بالتسبب في
تدمير السبت
تعرض سد كخفك للتدمير يمثل كارثه حقيقيه
بكل المقاييس فسدوا كخوفكا يحمل اهميه
اقتصاديه واستراتيجيه بالغه كما انه احد
اهم واكبر مشاريع البنيه التحتيه في
اوكرانيا اكثر من ذلك هو ان حجم التاثيرات
والاضرار التي قد تترتب عن انهياره كبيره
للغايه فالاف الاشخاص وعشرات القرى باتوا
معرضين لخطر الفيضانات
[موسيقى]
التهديدات ناجمه عن تفجير السد لا تتوقف
عند حدود اغراق القرى والمساكن بل تحمل
معها مخاطر نوويه وبيئيه فالتفجير اثار
مخاوف بشان محطه ذا فروج النوويه التي
تستخدم مياه هذا السد للتبريد الوكاله
الدوريه للطاقه الذريه دخلت على الخط في
محاوله ارسال تطمينات من خلال نفي وجود اي
خطر نووي اني في محطه اما على المستوى
البيئي فقد تسرب 150 طنا من زيت المحركات
الى نهر دنيبرو بعد انفجار السد كما افاد
مسؤولون اوكرانيون محذرين من اخطار بيئيه
معنى من واشنطن والعلاقات الدوليه دكتور
ادمون غريب دكتور ادموند في ضوء تبادل
الاتهامات بين الطرفين الروسي والاوكراني
كيف تقرا المغزى من استهداف هذه البنيه
التحتيه المدنيه في هذه الحرب نتحدث عن سد
كخوفكا طبعا
تحياتي لكم في نفس الوقت اعتقد اننا اذا
نظرنا الى ما يجري بان هذه كما ذكرتم قبل
قليل هي فعلا كارثه انسانيه خطره جدا هي
كارثه تهدد محطه النوويه التي تبرد
تستخدم مياه بالقرب من هذا السد
لتبريد المحطه هناك ايضا المياه التي تحصل
عليها شبه جزيره القرم من هذا من هذا السد
وذلك بعد ان عانت السكان هناك
لسنوات منذ 2014 من انقطاع قطع المياه
عنهم من قبل الحكومه الاوكرانيه في ذلك
الوقت
وايضا في في نفس الوقت الذي نرى ذلك كما
ذكرتم مخاطر بيئيه كبيره خاصه 90 الذي
يعني هناك الكميه الحقيقيه التي التي يعني
وقعت في هذه المنطقه
وبالاضافه الى ذلك هناك ايضا مخاطر على
الزراعه وهناك مخاطر ان الجانبين
الاوكراني والروسي كانوا قد زرعوا الكثير
من الالغام في هذه المنطقه
عند هذه النقطه الدكتور ادمون جون كربي
الناطق باسم مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
قال للصحفيين انه الولايات المتحده حاليا
لا يمكنها في هذه المرحله تحديد ما حصل
بشكل قاطع هل يعني هذا ضمنيا انه هناك
يعني ربما شك امريكي بان اوكرانيا بالفعل
هي التي فجرت السد
اعتقد ان الاداره الامريكيه تريد ان تكون
حذره ولكن في نفس الوقت نسمع من المسؤولين
امريكيين ومن مسؤولين في حلب شمال الاطلسي
اتهموا بالاضافه الى المسؤولين
الاوكرانيين اتهموا الروس بانه مهم
المسؤولين كما سمعنا من الروس انهم هم
الاخوانيين هم المسؤولين عن عمليه تفجير
ولكن في النهايه فعلا هناك سؤال اساسي من
هو المستفيد الاكبر
من تراه مستفيدا من تفجير سد كخوفك
فيخرسون
طبعا اعتقد ان الجانبين سيتاثران ولكن
يبدو ان التاثيرات على الاقل من المعلومات
الاوليه وهنا هناك حاجه فعلا لتحقيق حقيقي
حول ما حدث وما هي الاسباب لان هناك اولا
الاتهامات الاوكرانيه والغربيه وهناك
الاتهامات الروسيه المضاده وهناك ايضا
نظريه ثالثه تتحدث ان كانه كان هناك
انهيار
لجدار السد في عده مناطق وذلك بسبب رفع
كميه المياه التي كانت موجوده الى مستوى
لم يعد السد الذي كان يعاني على كل حال
منذ فتره
بالانهيار ولكن يبدو حتى الان ان المؤشرات
الاوليات تدل على ان اولا هذا سيؤثر اكثر
محطه
السيطره الروسيه معظم المناطق التي ستتاثر
مباشره هي تحت المناطق السيطره
القوات الروسيه وكذلك ايضا ان المياه التي
شبه جزيره القرم ايضا
منطقه تعتبرها روسيه جزءا
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا دكتور ادمون غريب استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه كنت معنا من واشنطن
اكدت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه على ان قواتها
تسيطر بشكل كامل على بلده برخيفكا بالقرب
من بخموت التي اتهمتها او اتهمها قائد
مجموعه فاقنر بالتنازل عنها جزئيا اوضحت
الوزاره ان الوحدات الروسيه نجحت في صدد
هدوم شانه مقاتلوا القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه مؤكده ان تخلي القوات الروسيه
المزعوم عن برخيفكا لا يتوافق مع الواقع
[موسيقى]
فتحت السفاره الايرانيه في الرياض ابوابها
بحضور مساعد وزير الخارجيه السعودي لشؤون
القنصليه علي اليوسف ونظره الايراني اضافه
الى القائم بالاعمال الايراني في السعوديه
حسن زارنكار وشمل الاحتفال رفع العلم
الايراني في السفاره وعددا من الكلمات
للمسؤولين الايرانيين وحضر الاحتفال
اعضاءه السلك الدبلوماسي في السعوديه من
دول الخليجيه وعربيه وغربيه اعاده
الافتتاح تاتي بعد ثلاثه اشهر من توقيع
الاتفاق السعودي الايراني لاستئناف
العلاقات بينهما برعايه صينيه
[موسيقى]
وفي مقابله مع العربيه اكد حسن نزارنكار
القائم باعمال السفاره الايرانيه في
الرياض ان اعاده افتتاح السفاره امر
ايجابي مؤكدا على ضروره عوده العلاقات لما
له ممنعه اقتصاديه وتجاريه على البلدين
والمنطق
[موسيقى]
وصل الى السعوديه وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
انطوني بلينكل لبحث التعاون الاستراتيجي
الامريكي السعودي في القضايا الاقليميه
والعالميه ومجموعه من القضايا الثنائيه
بما في ذلك التعاون الاقتصادي والامني
افادم ورسول العربيه ان زياره بلينكل
للسعوديه ستستغرق يومين حيث سيشارك في
اجتماع الوزاري لمجلس التعاون الخليجي
الامريكي كما سيحضر بلينكل مع وزير
الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن فرحان
اجتماعا الوزاريا للتحالف الدولي لهزيمه
داعش في الرياض لتسليط الضوء على الدور
الحاسم الذي يلعبه التحالف لمواجهه
التهديد المستمر لداعش
من جده معنا مراسل العربيه السلطان السلمي
سلطان اهلا بك كما شاهدنا في الصور بلنكن
وصل الى السعوديه هذا المساء جدول لقاءاته
واجندته في هذه الزياره الى السعوديه
اهلا بك صهيب اهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه بالفعل وصل وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انتوني بلينكل الى جده قبل ثلاثه
ساعات من الان وذلك لبدء زيارته الرسميه
الى السعوديه وبمقدمتها لقاء وللعهد
السعوديه الامير محمد بن سلمان وذلك قبيله
حضوره اجتماعي مهمين في العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض وهي اجتماع لمجلس التعاون الخليجي
الذي سوف يقام غدا الاربعاء وسوف يتراس مع
نظيره السعوديه الامير فيصل بن برحان وزير
الخارجيه السعودي اجتماعا للتحالف الدولي
لمكافحه تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه والذي
انشا في 2014 ويضم عشرات الدول والذي ايضا
سوف يقام في العاصمه السعوديه الرياضي يوم
الخميس القادم وكان قد قال اما السول
الامريكي في الخارجيه وهو دانيال بريم في
تصريح صحفي بانه نركز على اجنده متوافق
عليها والقدر كبير من العمل والذي سوف
يمكن البلدين من انجازه معا وسوف تتركز
المباحثات على العلاقات الاستراتيجيه
والجهود الراميه الى انهاء النزاعات في
السودان اليمن وكذلك المعركه المشتركه ضد
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه وايضا علاقات
الدول العربيه مع اسرائيل واذا قالت وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه في بيان ان بلينكن
سيلتقي بالمسؤولين السعوديين لمناقشه
التعاون الاستراتيجيه الامريكي السعودي في
القضايا الاقليميه وكذلك العالميه ومجموعه
من القضايا الثنائيه بين ابيما في ذلك
التعاون الاقتصادي واكيد التعاون الامني
بينما اكدت كذلك وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه
اليوم الثلاثاء قبل وصول وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي الى جده بان واشنطن ملتزمه
بتعزيز شركاتها الامنيه مع السعوديه بما
في ذلك المبيعات الدفاعيه والتدريبات
المشتركه وايضا مكافحه انتشار الصواريخ
والطيران المسير ايضا لدى الجهات غير
الحكومي ايضا قالت الوزاره في بيان لها
حول علاقات بين واشنطن والرياضه المملكه
ان التعاون مع السعوديه من اجل ضمان
الاستقرار الاقليمي ظل احدى ركائز
العلاقات الثنائيه بين الرياض واشنطن
وطبعا تاتي هذه الزياره بطبيعه الحال في
خضم تغير سريع لمشهد التحالفات في الشرق
الاوسط الذي بدا منذ ثلاثه اشهر بعد
الاتفاق السعودي الايراني الذي احيا
الامان بطبيعه الحال بحل النزاعات في
المنطقه سلطان السلمي من جده
كبير الجمهوريين في لجنه العلاقات
الخارجيه بمجلس شيوخ الامريكيه جيم ريتش
دعا اداره الرئيس جو بايدن الى تعزيز
العلاقات مع السعوديه باعتبارها شريكا
مهما اقتصاديا وامنيا لواشنطن ريتش قال ان
انه على مدى الثمانين عاما كانت السعوديه
شريكا في دعم المصالح الامنيه والاقتصاديه
المشتركه مشيرا الى ان اداره بايدن تاخرت
في تعزيز التعاون مع المملكه
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه
مصادر العربيه تؤكد عوده المحادثات غير
المباشره بين الجيش السوداني والدعم
السريع
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بصيص من الامل اطل مجددا
بخصوص الازمه السودانيه بعد تداول اخبار
عن استئناف المفاوضات بين طرفي النزاع
فنقلا عن مصادر قناه العربيه فان طرفي
النزاع استانفاه في مدينه جده السعوديه
المحادثات غير المباشره الراميه لوقف
اطلاق النار ونقلا عن مصادرنا دائما فان
المحادثات ستركز بالاساس على وقف القتال
[موسيقى]
التوتر يعود مجددا ليخيم على العلاقات
الاسرائيليه الامريكيه السبب تعيين رئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين نتنياهو
الصحفي جلعاد مستشارا اعلاميا له
فالمستشار الجديد اشتهر بتوجيههم انتقادات
لاذعه وصريحه للرئيس الامريكي الحالي لذا
فقد يشكل هذا التعيين ضربه للمساعي
المبدوله لتقريب وجهات النظر بين نتنياهو
والبيت الابيض المستشار الجديد لرئيس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه لم يكن يخفي معرضته
الشديده لبايدن كان قد كتب تغريدات ضد
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ادعى فيها انه
غير مؤهل ويدمر امريكا كما اكد انه قد ايد
ادعاءات مؤيدي الرئيس السابق بشان التزوير
الانتخابات الرئاسيه لعام 2020
قد عمل في القناه الرابعه عشره العبريه
وفي صحيفه اسرائيل اليوم التي تدعم
نتنياهو كما اشتهر بتاييد الرئيس الامريكي
السابق
وبمجرد تعيين حظيه تصريحات المستشار
الجديد لنتنياهو المنتقده لبايدن باهتمام
وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه وهو ما دفعه
الى كتابه تغريده اكد فيها انه لا يحمل
الان نفس الاراء بخصوص بايدن واكدا انه
سيعمل بشكل احترافيا تماما في مكتب رئيس
الوزراء
نتابع من حيفا عبر سكايب مع
المحلل السياسي ومن واشنطن طارق الشامل
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي مرحبا بكما ضيفي
الكريمين ابدا معك سيد يوئف كيف يفهم
تعيين قلعه هذا المنصب المهم في وقت
من الاطراف تحسين وتلطيف الاجواء بين
نتنياهو بايدن اولا يجب ان نفهم انه هذا
هو اسلوبنا ودائما يفضل نتنياهو مستشارين
له الذي لديهم اراء هناك خلاف عليها لماذا
لكي يسوق نفسه كاكثر اعتدالا منهم هو يعني
في سابق ايضا عين مستشارين
مكربين له
نشروا في العديد من وسائل الاعلام اليمنيه
الموجوده اليوم في اسرائيل اراء ضد
الاداره الامريكيه او ضد العرب بشكل عام
ضد جهات مختلفه وبعد ذلك
عينهم لهذه المناسب لكي يكون محاط بكل من
يفكر نوعا ما مثله بينما هو بشكل شخصي
يبتعد من هذه الاراء واضح طيب سيد طارق
الشامي مره يكفي ما قاله
السيد يقف هل فعلا نتنياهو يعين من اقصى
اليمين حتى يبدو هو معتدلا ام هذا التعيين
ضربه قاسمه لكل الجهود لراس الصدع بين
نتنياهو بايدن
اعتقد انه نتنياهو يريد ارسال رساله واضحه
الى الاداره الامريكيه وهو انه غير مرتاح
لمواقفها التي يصفها احيانا بالتدخل في
الشؤون الاسرائيليه حينما اعرب بايدن في
وقت سابق عن عدم او قلقه اتجاه ما يسمى
بالاصلاح القضائي او يعني تعديل النظام
القضائي هو ايضا يريد ارسال رساله بان
بانه استخدم مستشارا يمكن له من خلال
مواقفه السابقه وفي وقت ما من الحملات
الانتخابيه القادمه ربما يطلق تصريحات
مماثله يؤيد فيها الجمهوريين وبخاصه
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب الذي يحظى
بشعبيه اكبر عن خصومه حتى الان حتى عن
ديزانتس وبالتالي هو يمكن ان يكون ذلك
مثيرا للقلق لدى الاداره الامريكيه خصوصا
وان بايدن لم يوجه اي دعوه
نتنياهو كي يزوره في البيت الابيض حسبما
جر في تقليد الامريكي الاسرائيلي نعم سيد
يقف يعني هل ترى انه العلاقه الامريكيه
الاسرائيليه قد اصابها الضرر من خلال هذه
الرساله ام كما تفضلت في بدايه حديثك انه
الاداره الامريكيه تنظر يعني الى برغماتيه
نتنياهو في هذا التعيين
لا نعرف اصلا حتى الان ما نعرفه هو
نشر بالفعل مثل ما
تفضلتوا
تغريده يقول فيها انه هذه الاغاني لا
تمثله الان هو لم يكن لنا شرف فلنسمع ما
هي الاراء الجديده لتزفيك ولكن كما يبدو
ليس هناك
نيه في مكتب الرئيس الوزراء بان تكون هناك
ضربه او اي ضرر للعلاقات مع الولايات
المتحده نعرف تماما نعم لم يتم دعوه حتى
الان الى البيت الابيض كما كان صحيح
معتاد في العلاقات ما بين دولتين هناك
مشكله في العلاقات ما بين الطرفين
وجلاد سبيك المقرب لابنه لنتنيويا نتنياه
واخرين
المقربين نتنياهو دائما كانوا ينشرون
اخبار تتعلق بما يجري في سياسه الامريكيه
كانوا يقفون دائما
وهذه هي هذه هذا هو الواقع يجب يعني يجب
ان يكون هناك اعتراف واضح بانه موقف
نتانيان اقرب الى ترند مما هو قريب لاي
رئيس اخر في الولايات المتحده اي شخصيه
طارق شاميك قال بعد تعيينه مستشرا اعلاميا
لنتنياهو انه لم يعد يحمل نفس الاراء عن
بايدن كما كان يغرد في السابق هل برايك
الاداره الامريكيه يمكن ان تتغاضى عن هذا
التعيين
يعني ليس من حق الاداره الامريكيه ان تعلق
على هذا الامر فهذا شان داخلي يتعلق
باسرائيل ومن حقنه ان يعين ما يشاء لكنها
بالتاكيد هي تشعر بقدر من القلق لانه
استقدم شخص اخر من اليمين المتشدد المعروف
بمواقفه العدائيه تجاه الاداره واتجاه
الديمقراطيين بشكل عام وهو ايضا يروج لنفس
الفكره التي يروج لها ترامب واعوانه الذين
يقولون بان الانتخابات السابقه في 2020 قد
سرقت وبالتالي هناك مخاوف من ان يعزز هذا
الطيار المتشدد الاسرائيلي وهناك ايضا من
ينسجمون معه حتى في داخل الامريكي في لدى
اليمين المتشدد وما يسمى بمجموعه ماجه
التي تدعم الرئيس دونالد ترامب
يجب ايضا ان نضع هذا في السياق اخر وهو
كون ان حتى المفكر في رئيس مجلس النواب هو
الشخصيه الثانيه كرئيس مجلس نواب امريكي
الذي يدلي بخطاب في الكنيسه الاسرائيلي
والذي سبقه ايضا كان متشدد اخر هو
في عام 98 في عهد رئيس ديمقراطي هو في هذا
الوقت وكان هو يعني يمثل حزب الشاي
المتشدد في اليمين
الامريكي في صياغ في كل هذا السياق هناك
رساله واضحه بان هناك دعم من حكومه
نتنياهو وهو كان في السلطه على ما يبدو في
هذا الوقت ايضا انه مستمر في نفس السياق
التوائم مع اليمين الامريكي وخصوصا التيار
المتشدد الذي يرى انه يحقق مصالحه وهو
يريد ان يحدث ما يريد احداثه في تعديل
النظام القضاء الاسرائيلي بحيث لا تكون
هناك ديمقراطيه حقيقيه يمتلك السلطه
الكافيه لتمرير ما يشاء في النظام
الاسرائيلي طارق شامل الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي من واشنطن
المحلل السياسي من حيفا شكرا جزيلا لكما
[موسيقى]
وبعد قليل ايضا في اخبار الساعه موجه
جديده من الحرائق في مدينه اوتاوا الكنديه
والدخان يغطي سماء المدينه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد بدات موجه جديده من
الحرائق في مدينه اوتاوا الكنديه حيث افاد
عمده المدينه ان النيران لا تزال مشتعله
وان الدخان يغطي سماء المدينه بشكل كامل
الامير هاري يجذب الانظار من جديد بظهوره
داخل ردهات المحاكم الامير المثير للجدل
بات اول فرد الرفيع المستوى في الاسره
المالكه البريطانيه يدلي بشهادته في
المحكمه منذ ازيد من قرن وتعود فصول
القضيه الى الدعوه القضائيه التي رفعها
الامير هاري واكثر من مئه شخصيه بارزه
اخرى ضد مؤسسه
ووجهت للمؤسسه التي تصدر صحف ديلي ميرور
تهم اختراق هواتف هذه الشخصيه البارزه بين
عامي 91 و20011 ورفضت مجموعه ميرور تهم
التنصت الموجه اليها لكنها اعترفت
بمحاولتها ذات مره الحصول على معلومات
بشكل غير قانوني عن الامير هاري وبالتالي
يحق له الحصول على تعويض عن ذلك
الامير هاري المعروف بتوجيهه انتقادات
اللاذعه للصحافه البريطانيه جهز ملفا
متكاملا لمقاضاه مجموعه ميرور
وسيدقق القاضي بالتفصيل في 33 نموذجا من
القصص الخبريه المنشوره في الذيل
وذلك من اصل
147 قصه يقول محاموهاري انها نتاج جمع
اخبار بطريقه غير قانونيه
وبهذه الاخبار تنتهي اخبار الساعه لهذه
الليله شكرا على المشاهده الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات